voici ci lui voûte
et
bonjour m'a dit il mon temps c'était pas
possible manon il est mort ah bon bah
oui à chavez
sylvie vous de bonsoir alors avec vous
on change pas de sujet on va rester dans
la drogue
mais yves roques acceptée par la société
puisque c'est celle que prennent les
coureurs cyclistes avec la femme de
villy woot soigneur de l'équipe festina
arrêté en 1998 ce qui a déclenché la
plus grosse affaire de l'histoire et on
l'avait reçue ici votre votre mari willy
pour son deuxième livre qui s'appelait
sexe mensonges et petit vélo maladie
tout est dit récemment à l'occasion de
la sphère cofidis des femmes de du
coureur ou des femmes de soigneurs ont
peu le cas des femmes de doper ont pris
la parole pour raconter leur vie brisée
et dénoncer la loi du milieu il ya ellis
gaumont il ya le rates chauty et vous
sylvie vote alors vous dites six ans
après festina rien n'a changé en fait ou
plutôt si maintenance et des
transfusions sanguines des produits
vétérinaires mais en fait c'est toujours
la même chose qu'à l'époque de l'affairé
festina
mais en résumé on va dire ça n'a pas
servi le sang en gros ça servi
strictement à rien le problème il est là
et ce qui se passe c'est que chez
festina par la force des choses il avait
essayé de
d'un petit peu contrôlées par des
médecins par le directeur sportif
histoire d'éviter de faire n'importe
quoi ce qui veut pas dire que c'était
bien je ne dis pas ça les questions se
retrouve six ans après puisque qu est-ce
qu on se retrouve avec des transfusions
de des autotransfusions des produits
vétérinaires dans des camions dans des
camping-cars qui suivent la caravane de
toutes les courses sans suivi médical
s'en suivit oui sarkozy va mettre des
flics dans les écoles pourquoi il aurait
pas des flics qu'il fallait contrôle
antidopage je dis que simplement et
sarkozy mais des flics dans les écoles
ça imbsheim un petit peu la population
et c'est normal parce que je trouve
c'est complètement nul mais bon fermons
la parenthèse
quand les filles ont fait des descentes
ou sur le tour de france ou sur le tour
d'italie ça fait un drame il ya eu quand
même grève des coureurs tout le monde
s'est arrêté parce que c'est dramatique
the day the toute façon ils vivent dans
une sphère est dans un milieu qui est à
part donc ils sont dans leur monde
ils sont au contrôle c'est comme si vous
aviez un directeur de société qui a la
foi qui à la fois généraliste
voilà c'est je veux dire c'est comme les
hommes politiques et surtout en gros
comment il va où il y ait besoin de la
méridienne on voit le jour et la dre
jocelyne et là tu te souviens nous les
voûtes c'est la lenteur du bo belge et
alimentaire c'est parce que je dénonce
un brevet soit déposé quelque part
pendant le procès mais les impôts après
avec lui on n'a pas dormi pendant trois
semaines ils ont plus de drogue là non
je suis en art et il est trop tard mardi
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait là de quoi
evil sérieusement là il travaille dans
une société de son sport oui voilà
et vous vous travaillez toujours la
fonction publique jours thierry vous
étouffe des impôts non pas un truc
dommage pourquoi je travaille dans une
collectivité territoriale
cette voie là alors justement quand vous
avez rencontré où il veut dans 1983 bon
vous travaillez déjà dans la fonction
publique à l'époque ville des
pharmaciens
les médias soigneur est alors le soir
comme ça à l'époque j'étais assez cool
me dit vous en parliez sur un coin de
table parler du dopage que vous auriez
parler d'autre chose si vous avez été
maçon ou boulanger quoi c'est tellement
j'étais assez normal mais ça prenait pas
des proportions fait à l'époque
doucement avec les maçons non mais c'est
vrai à l'époque ce n'était pas un drame
c'était pas du tout un drame est que ça
restait vraiment demandé dans des
proportions va dire fait normal job
déraisonnable déjà mais non mais c'était
pas un souci parce que ça reste et ça
reste et ça ne vous fait pas la vie
quand on a bouffé après quoi les médias
quand même le perron les hormones de
croissance personnelle corticaux
anabolisants donc à la fin des années 80
les pratiques étaient assez limitées
discrète raisonnable ouais ensuite 5 80
début 90 c'est arrivé avec le cyclisme
italien avait des avoirs italien lteo
voilà les italiens camil perron et de la
bon c'est vrai que ça a complètement
dégénéré et le tournant ça a été en 95
là ça commençait à devenir un avenir
très chaud parce que c'était plus des
soins des préparations mais c'est
carrément de la drogue ce qui se passe
vous parler me parler comme le milieu
thierry attention avant soit une
préparation sur l'impréparation c'est le
mot qui ne parlait pas de dopage voilà
on n'allait pas faire je ne parlais pas
de dopage de l'accès de l'extérieur par
l'image
et là ça commençait très chaud dont 95
96 que les mecs sont devenus accros à
leur truc c'est arrivé c'est vrai avec
toute une génération de coureurs
italiens hollandais
d'ailleurs il ya eu des décès ça a été
quand même dramatique
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi appris bon de
je suis pas que bruno roussel à essayer
d'encadrer ça c'était c'était à la
limite beaucoup plus intelligente que de
laisser faire ce la distribution potion
magique mais embellissent non pas cette
fois ci ceux des amphétamines la caféine
de l'héroïne de la cocaïne quoi de faire
les courses parce que ça c'était
détectable contrôle entier ils prenaient
ça à l'entraînement et après il y avait
le côté complètement festif vous prenez
ce en soirée pour de wii fit wii jusqu'à
incroyable c'est qu'en fait ils
prenaient du pot belge faut pour
l'entraînement mais ils on prenait aussi
pour faire des soirées ils ont prôné
pourquoi les frères ainsi donc il était
drogué
donc j'étais dans ces départements
extérieurs de l'extérieur on disait ça
mais eux non c'était quelque chose qui
était conseil c'est vraiment qu'il
baigne c'est dans leur langage le dopage
et le dopage la dope et la drogue
on a envoyé neuf fois en tête donc les
gens prennent pour faire des fêtes vous
vous alliez à des fêtes de coire
cyclistes et puis vous étiez un peu
largué vous amusez pas comme les autres
et vous avez essayé d'en prendre
oui deux fois piqûre dans l'épaule ouais
et alors ça vous a fait quoi
elle a fait deuxième vous êtes resté
éveillé toute la nuit
ouais jusqu'à 10h à wemmel à total est
par le comble c'est après c'est la
période 95 98 alors là ça commence
sérieusement à bouffer votre vie de
famille
vous dites dans le bac à légumes du
frigo et plus de produits dopants que
d'autres choses enfouies périmètre un
temps mi temps un proto feu de près aux
deux places 5e journée jeudi le frigo
était à moitié à mon mari ouais c'est ce
qui lui c'est quoi le budget comme dans
une équipe le budget calmes mais il faut
demander au courant parce que c'est eux
qui paient ce avec leurs primes
est ce qu'ils gagnaient au noir sur hit
west directeur d'équipé mais ne se
sentait pas bien parce que je veux dire
c'est il obliger personne à la moi j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un qu'on a jamais vu
alors là donc vous vous refusez
finalement que les gens viennent se
servir chez vous en voulez pas ce qui
fait que votre mari will il est obligé
de remplir son coffre et de faire le
tour d'europe pour suivre les cours et
pour les prestations mitigées des 100
métiers comme la gym glaciaire aussi
qu'est ce qui faisait où il est voûte
pour tenir là pour tenir le coup bas ils
en prenaient aussi comme les autres ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que le
soigneur en prenez la peine des
soignants poignet en matinée de samedi
soir elle a pris deux fois
enfin bon et les parents prennent voilà
ici principalement quand même et à ce
moment là vous dites ça devient
complètement obsessionnelle les piqûres
avant la course
vous dites j'en ai plus parlé de sport
quoi c'était ça on n'entendait plus
parler de sport on entendait parler de
soi une préparation normale de
croissance de p o et de contrôle de haut
voilà on n'entendait plus du tout parler
des sports c'était devenu secondaire
d'ailleurs si vous regardez une caravane
du train une caravane du tour de france
vous avez à peu près 5000 ses mille
personnes pour 200 coureurs dans les
terres maintenant et c'est là en 1998
donc et 4 affaire festina
bruno roussel le patron de l'équipe
festina vous appelle il vous dit brûle
les carnets dis à ton mari qui prennent
tout sur lui on a tout payé
on va partir et on va s'arranger parti
comme ça parce que moi j'ai appris mon
mari est en prison par un coup de
téléphone de la police judiciaire en me
disant dans votre mari il va bien je
vais vous passez deux minutes vous posez
aucune question voilà bon donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe
le lendemain en fait ce qui vous a
énervé c'est que donc on vous demande
audi voilà il va tout prendre mais c'est
pas grave on va payer
et le lendemain vous voyez le départ de
l'étape et là ils sont tous contents
comme si de rien était elle de rien
n'était je commence par entendre une
roue celle qui dit je comprends pas qu
est ce qui se passe parce que mon équipe
est au complet et il me manque personne
et
bon les coureurs entre autres à l'époque
qui dit je connais à peine j'ai pas
qu'est ce que c'est si trafic pour les
autres pas au courant je me suis pincé
parce que j'ai dit mais qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'ils me racontent parce que moi
j'ai débuté en juillet avec sa perf
je veux dire dans les chambres d'hôtel
c'était avec la m'énerve quand vous
décidez vous dit
chacun joue dans son camp catalan moi je
suis moi aussi eu et voilà on va pas
tout prendre sans rien faire non j'ai
dit moi j'ai rappelé bruno rousset
allait revenir là mais j'ai dit c'est
bon je compris tout de suite il fallait
pas jouer ce jeu unités morts donc au
lieu de brûler les carnets vous le
cacher je n'ai des cas chez nous ça nous
chez une amie paysanne voilà dans les
tables des vaches voilà alors pendant
qu'on écoute maintenant tout le temps
que tout le monde le juge tout le monde
perd parce que moi j'ai eu droit la
perquisition la maison c'est la totale
le frigo était vide parce que quand il
est parti pour le tour j'ai dit je
strictement plus rien la maison du conte
toute la merde et tu la gère les routes
et malgré ça vous avez gardé de l'amour
pour willy lagarde et de l'amour pour
vous malgré ça votre continent à
patienter rien il faut demander ça ouais
bah vous voyez bien quand même
ça va toujours la voilà enfin en tous
les cas à l'instruction vous produirez
ses fameux carnets que vous aviez sauver
de sauver du feu
mais à l'époque cette menace et vous
recevez beaucoup de coups de fil
anonymes le soir la nuit
anonyme de qui je m'entends c'est
embêtant c'est métrage eu toujours des
couilles qui font ça j'ai dit que j'en
ai voilà en fait votre mari a parlé aux
procès mais ça aurait changé quoi ça
arrive apparemment ça rien changé la
seule chose c'est que maintenant on peut
plus dire qu'il fait ils ne peuvent plus
dire qu'ils savent pas comment ça se
passe
qu'est ce qu'ils risquent je pense que
c'est vrai à l'époque personne savait ce
qu'ils risquaient parce que quand il se
faisait attraper il ya eu x fois où se
sont quand même fait attraper ou à une
frontière et attraper faits vérifiés
loris temps sur terre donna une
casquette en cuissard et maillot vert
tout était mort
dédicaces et photos et ça roulait sa
part où les sap a roulé ce qui me
scandalise le plus c'est que les
personnes qui parlent sont bannis du
milieu c'est ça si je veux arriver à
vous avec moi tellement personnellement
je m'en fous moi je me demande c'est on
est venu demander mon témoignage je dis
volontiers je dis la vérité je trouve
que c'est complètement nul 2-2 rien dire
alors tout le monde dit on veut faire
avancer les choses et personne ne parle
il faut que ça soit encore une fois les
femmes qui parlaient de toute façon le
problème il est là au lieu de ben ali
sont une poignée à avoir parlé et au
lieu de les bannir je veux dire de les
mettre complètement de côté c'est les
gros méchants qui ont fait exploser la
bulle prend l'expérience des gens qui
savent le problème des contrôles
antidopage c'est qu'ils ont une
génération de coureurs de retard ils ont
dix ans le pays est arrivé 5 80 début 90
premiers contrôles de le paix au 1er
janvier 98 voilà donc 8 en 8 9 10 ans
voilà une génération
en gros sont en train de se mettre dans
les fesses actuellement ça sera ça
sortira dandy d'emploi trouveront les
contrôles en disant que je peux faire
rien maintenant
maintenant tout de suite la même chose
qu'eux mais qu'est ce que ben écoutez
écoutez les gens qui savent comment ça
fonctionne
qu'on leur dise comment ça fonctionne et
peut-être pourquoi pas un coming out
c'est à la mode comme des sportifs ça
commence un petit peu il faut sauver ou
les routes non tu penses quoi de tout ça
c'est insensé quand même toi tu te fais
serré tout [ __ ] en taule pour
exactement les mêmes trucs et il fait
maintiendrait les mecs qui font le tour
de france je n'ai pas gagné d'étape
la preuve que ça sert à rien de toute
façon la preuve c'est que chez festina
il y avait dopage qui était organisée
depuis trois quatre cinq ans exactement
que je sais plus et ils se sentent
jamais fait choper un contrôle ils
s'enfuient jamais ils se sont fait chaud
c'est mon mari qu'il fait c'est ce qui
s'est fait choper voilà un bar il ya
actuellement les mecs qui se dit sportif
qui se font attraper ces pluies c'est lé
plus couillon du peloton le chez festina
et les contrôles inopinés étaient au
courant le jour et l'heure auxquelles
d'avoir lieu dont copine inopinés donc
conclusion des courses
le tout c'était de pas se faire choper
avec plus de 50% de taux d'hématocrite
dans le sang hop on a vu il avait une
petite machine par laquelle il
contrôlait le sly avec 52,73 perfusion
d'autres on faisait descendre le taux
s'était finie très compliqué pourquoi
ces dix pas les mecs qui vient de parler
c'est des trucs
peut-être me flinguer en sortant mais
non alors tous les cas merci d'avoir
témoigné merci dit